denis balbir accusé de sexisme doit-il
être sanctionné denis tout le monde en
parle depuis hier le journaliste sportif
denis balbir à une déclaration qui a
beaucoup fait parler
alors qu'il était interviewé sur le tv
mag il a déclaré qu'une femme ne peut
pas commenter les matchs de foot on se
fait un petit récap de l'histoire alors
sortie malheureuse ou est-ce qu'il doit
être sanctionné vous nous dites ci doit
être sanctionnée c'est parti décidément
en ce moment les commentateurs de
football font beaucoup parler d'eux
quelques jours seulement après la
polémique autour de laurent paganelli
c'est au tour d'un confrère de m6
d'attirer l'attention après une
déclaration pour le moins maladroite
invitée du buzz tv denis balbir s'est
exprimé sur la place des femmes au
commentaire d'un match de football
commenter le foot masculin par une femme
moi je suis content j'ai compte pourquoi
parce qu'une femme elle pourra jamais
avoir un timbre de voix où je sais pas
dans une action de folie pourra jamais
avoir aidé à monter dans les aigus donc
et ça va être forcément peut-être un
petit peu plus délicat de l'esp est
supporté les propos qui ont tout de
suite fait réagir sur internet
le journaliste également présent sur rtl
n'a pas fait l'unanimité non plus auprès
de ses collègues
la société des journalistes de la
station a même publié un communiqué de
presse à son encontre face à cette
polémique qui prend de plus en plus
d'importance denis balbir a tenu à
apaiser les tensions sur son compte
twitter je regrette la mauvaise
interprétation de mes propos je côtoie
depuis des années des femmes dans le
journaliste et travaille avec des
consultantes de grande valeur je n'ai
jamais remis en cause leur
professionnalisme une femme peut bien
sûr commenter un match de football pour
rappel denis balbir avait été suspendu
de w9 en avril dernier pour des propos
homophobes tenus hors antenne après le
match om là qui alors denis balbir
accusé de sexisme doit-il être
sanctionné est ce que ça vous choque
bout en viennent à toi s'attache aux
quais ces propos là ou pas c'est très
maladroit je vois ce qui veut dire
parfois sur des plateaux quand une femme
est assistante et qu'à hurler ses fruits
que si ses aigus ces diagrammes et
toutes les femmes n'ont pas des voix
aiguë et puis
ya des hommes qui ont des bois très
désagréable aussi donc c'est très
maladroit très sûr c'est pas moi c'est
pas moderne c'est sexy c'est maladroit
alors denis que je connais peu de
raymond aussi franchement alors je veux
moi je défends voilà je défends pas
voilà ces propos mais en tout cas lui il
est pas vraiment je pense pas que ce
soit misogyne ou sexistes non il a eu un
mot malheureux je pense y narre vraiment
ce qu'ils voulaient dire voilà je vous
dis pas ce que je lui vois l'accord est
bon très bon vous l'avez eue au
téléphone ou alors ils veulent
sanctionner de nice un gars adorable moi
je pense qu il a déconné parce qu'il n'a
pas à dire ce à quoi ça peut bien sûr
qu'on aurait aussi on ne sait pas finie
femme elle peut commenter vu qu'on agit
donc en deux oui en deux elle est là est
d'ailleurs camille abily
elle commente avec lui son doublé avec
trois sorties comme ça il commente à
côté d'une femme et à l'échec selon
tacle excellente et c'est un excellent
duo tous les deux après moi ce que je
pense c'est qu'il a fait une analyse
technique de sinistres il aurait dû
faire comme les autres
hypocrite et se taire face au monde qui
ont la même chose sauf qu'il allait de
bonheur
déjà dans les rues du foot mon numéro et
une nulle part une faille en aurait
alors il assis là il a raison il ya une
petite hypocrisie il n'y a pas une qui a
été une fois de numéro un dans les
commentaires et je pense que ça devrait
géraldine vous seriez excellente par
exemple que les excellentes non mais je
gagnais 30 soit jamais une fan numéro un
donc je finis 30 secondes et moi j'étais
quand j'étais petit je regardais sur
téléfoot marianne mako elle a été la
première est amarré au port dernièrement
nous a quittés dernièrement j'ai pas vu
de tweets de gens s'insurgent et grasse
et b la stella félicitations rien ils
s'en foutent complètement
quand c'est pas [ __ ] le bordel ils
sont là après c'est pas bien ce qu'il a
fait pour moi il a déconné il n'aurait
pas dû dire ça c'est sûr qu'il est
décodé mais bon je ne m'arrêtais de la
première question est ce que raymond
doit retourner chauffeur livreur
fait super déçu par la non mais ce qui
est des colas et que comme ils
travaillent avec denis balbir et lance
pas dire la vérité ça c'est de
travailler avec lui ça c'est pas bien
parce que bâle où il étudie le verdict
et jean van hamme donné quoi 30 bal 50
balles j'essaye va pas me faire vivre
deux niveaux il a beaucoup et pas y
penser ça et vous n'avez pas le monopole
du journalisme de ce fonds moi je me
suis aussi mal pire on lui pardonne une
fois avec ses propos homophobes et là
faudrait encore lui pardonner c'est trop
cyril vous avez volé mais moi aussi je
les aime bien mais c'est inacceptable
c'est machiste c'est sexiste
il peut pas continuer comme ça s'il
pense vraiment ça il faut le virer
largement moi j'ai regardé le match j'ai
coupé le son alors jouer ce qu'il a dit
est totalement crétin
on est bien d'accord là dessus en
revanche chaque faute si à chaque fois
que quelqu'un dit une connerie
bon on le sanctionne toi tu es plus
leurs émissions jusqu'en 2015
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dgo j'ai déjà tenu des propos homophobes
et de toute façon j'ai pas dit qu'il
tenait des propos sexistes qui ponctuent
le calme pas il nous fait une castaldi
je tiens je tiens quand même à préciser
que gilles verdez n'a jamais tenu de
propos sexistes dans cette émission
s'est passé
chaque âge il est absolument délicieuse
et un amour ça n'a rien à voir
simplement il est délicieux mets parfois
une idée comme souplesse j'aimerais
avoir l'avis doit-il être sanctionnés ou
pas chaque mois elle a voulu dire
quelque chose c'est un dérapage que
celui qui n'a jamais péché lui jette la
première pierre qui avait parlé de
l'amour me fait peur et si vous y allez
il a déjà les voilà déjà qui est en
train de dire voilà que moi et mes
raisons il faut le sanctionner parce que
quand on la verra pépins on a alors est
une somme que j'aime dans la vie de
mathieu de l'an bon si vous le
sanctionner pour vous oui pourquoi vous
êtes très dur non je suis pas très dur
il y en a marre qu'on masquer des me par
le mot de maladresse des choses c'est ce
qu'aime très importante
il ya eu le mot phobie tout à l'heure
vous l'avais dit je ne dis pas qu'il est
homophobe je dis qu'il ya eu un dérapage
sur l'homophobie
tout à l'heure vous avez montré encore
une agression qu elle retrouve enfin
c'est très dangereux
et là il a fait une sortie encore qui
est très qui n'est pas maladroite parce
que derrière maladresse en général ça
cache une pensée je ne connais pas ce
monsieur te dis juste qu'il faut qu'je
dans sanction parce que sinon à chaque
fois qu'il y aura une erreur on dira
maladresse et dans le tout d'après
humaine inverse da pardon ça passe pas
alors isabelle morini bosc
moi je suis entièrement d'accord avec ce
qu'est pour le tenait alors on rappelle
qu'il est sur m6
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
la société des journalistes s'est
insurgé contre et oui parce que je
trouve que le principe de la sanction
m'ad'abord faut arrêter avec ça réclamer
l'indulgence pour lui c'est réclamé
l'indulgence aussi pour nous si demain
après demain ou dans trois jours on dit
une connerie ont conduit dans les dom
tom
imaginez moi avec la voix que j'ai si je
commande du football effectivement je
vais monter dans les aigus les arêtes
nous la fait qu'aujourd'hui la droit
parce que des phares été maladroit non
y'a vraiment des bois des voix aiguë
mais faut arrêter c'est un pastis quoi
s'attelle sur un billot c'est finalement
de ne plus aimer il avait la joie de le
défendre et à la lan c'est vrai que ne
fait on pas voir
ddd des propos maladroits après voilà
c'est vrai qu'on est là on est tous
contre les propos de denis
mais voilà est-ce qu'il faut le
sanctionner donc vous vous battez au
rire et on évite une sangle sûr aimé
donc vous vous le verrez vous n'ont
jamais la vie voilà une sanction ça peut
être une mise à pied quelques jours ça
fait deux fois qui dérape la première
fois en excuses la deuxième des
sanctions
jean-michel à admet matthieu collin
qu'aujourd'hui depuis quelques années il
ya une sorte de chasse aux sorcières de
dictature du sexisme du sexisme n'est
que tu dis là moindre farce à
interpréter interprété comme du texte a
fait malheureusement que vous êtes
rumeurs quand j'ai vu malheur il ya
quelques mois de faire un tweet en
disant que le foot féminin je trouvais
ça chiant je me suis pris des centaines
de tweets maison j'étais sexy ce que je
retourne aux ménages
là j'ai répondu à 10 ans j'ai désolé
pour moi le sexy l'a été pour les femmes
c'est plus d'égalité les salaires
avaient pas
on dirait des doux dingues son souffle
moi j'avais des choses à l'équipe de
lyon j'aime beaucoup
il m'avait écrit pour dire tu es
sexistes qui connaît mal jura et ben moi
j'ai répondu que l'égalité des hommes
femmes ce n'est plus dans les salaires
on était obligé de s'extasier sur tout
ce que vous avez fait avoir par adam
levine 2009 mm
ben voilà bien parce qu'il est dans la
bien bon sens maintenant le football
doit nous servir pour cent vous y
connaissez rien au foot de mieux en
mieux
la formule 1 je serais ravi qu'une fille
comment ta formule 1 et pourtant il ne
commet pas ironie du sort il ya dix ans
il y avait un journal de foot qui avait
écrit un papier un édito satirique sur
denis balbir et qui avait dit que
c'était le rocco siffredi des cordes
vocales et qu'il avait une wii une
grotte hypertrophié en fait en dix ans
ce groupe c'était une catastrophe parce
qu'il monte dans les aigus ralenti
commenté il avait été furieux il avait
porté plainte contre ce journal est au
bout de deux procès le journal a
effectivement mis la clé sous la porte
donc la réponse du lot de 28 centimes
annoncé un journal foot c'est un peu
d'humour et je trouve que effectivement
je trouve qu'il est un peu coincé un peu
compliqué pour un journaliste se trouve
de porter plainte contre deux
journalistes
alors je vous dis il ya six mois à
tweetos avait publié une vidéo de denis
balbir vous en avait parlé en off bien
sûr qu'ils n'étaient pas passés sur w9
on voyait le commentateur voilà parler
des adversaires qui affronter l'om à
l'époque et c'est pour ça que vous dites
voilà ça fait deux fois oui
maladresse c'est une fois maladresse et
d'une maladresse a light a fait le
connaissant un petit peu et raymond
aussi je vous le dis il n'est pas du
tout comme ça voilà même est alors
qu'ils disent pas ça sert tout ça brille
le stade quand il est comme ça si je
suis bien content pour ccpd arrogant au
match aller l'a commise était sûr de
gagner froid rien là vous allez pas des
formes serrer la main en famille c'est
un mec bien voilà on l'a prétendu
d'ailleurs je connais moi oui j'aime
l'italie je le connais un petit peu
voilà et voilà moi j'aime pas voilà je
suis là où l'on sait d'eux ces deux
dérapages ont la vie c'est des dérapages
donc s'il sait des dérapages c'est qu'on
n'est pas on n'est pas pour ce qu'il a
fait non juste le truc c'est que moi
j'aime pas les lynchages médiatiques ou
de se mettre sur lui voilà c'est tout
oui mais la série laisse des conneries
et mathieu le premier et tout le monde
ici sait en tout cas mais votons avec
mépris que sais je vais le défendre pour
ce qui n'était pas une non mais pas le
grand désordre qui fait j'ai passé ma
turbo pas là ils l'ont pourrissent un
match de coupe d'europe pour marseille
est éliminé ouais mais ça y'a pas des
excuses en arrière bonne excuse pour ça
c'est d'accord c'est alors maintenant
trouver gens trouvent parce que il a eu
une journée difficile ce jour mais la
raison là vous vous je vous aime
beaucoup mais là vous en foutez là
c'était unique c'est sa mère qui l'a dit
lui-même d'ailleurs donné tout ce qu'ils
avaient pu d'adidas excusé après cyril
avec un tweet sur les femmes ce qu'il a
dit c'est inexcusable aussi mais est-ce
qu'on doit le sanctionner ou pas c'est
la question que je pose aux
téléspectateurs ont zappé daniel je
pense que ça peut pas rester impuni il
faut évidemment pas le clou et regarder
marcel campion avec un dérapage of sur
les [ __ ] entre guillemets ça à sa
carrière il arrête sa carrière donc il
faut quand même ça peut plus être
recollés c'est comme ça sans qu'on fait
les choses
alors il ya plein de journalistes
inconnu même femme yann leur bonne et
que j'aime beaucoup voilà qu'il clique
qui est tombée dessus sur twitter ne
cachez pas votre misogynie derrière
l'excusé fallacieux du timbre de voix
les femmes n'ont pas le monopole des
aigus voilà l appeler marlène schiappa
donc là la ministre ne laissez pas les
jeunes filles penser qu'elles n'ont pas
leur place aux commentaires via israël
denis aussi qui voilà qui est qu'avec a
répondu qui a dit je pense que nous les
femmes on a une voix qui est plus aiguë
que celle des hommes
un max et 1h30 ça ne vous a pas échappé
au bout d'une heure trente entendre une
voix un peu plus aigus l'oreille je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit ce qui est de
mieux donc elle est d'accord avec denis
balbir estelle denis qui est je dis la
vérité qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec estelle mine de rien c'est
quelqu'un d'exceptionnel parce que le
sommet tout le monde à dos
en twittant ça est imminent rien elle y
va elle essaie de défendre son peuple
même si voilà elle n'est pas d'accord
avec lui je pense au fond mais elle est
quand même c'est quand même bien voilà
c'est l'un des spectateurs sont très
partagés dans cette histoire mais voilà
alors il lui il a dit je regrette la
mauvaise interprétation des propos
choquants toit depuis des années des
femmes dans le journalisme et travaille
avec des consultantes de grande valeur
je n'ai jamais remis en cause leur
professionnalisme une femme peut bien
sûr commenter un match de foot
regardez là le sondage les chéris le
sondage
we had y'at-il cette solide et oui vous
êtes une majorité à penser qu'il doit
être sanctionné